in my lung is Java nearly six months
after his son died mientos says every
day is a struggle that is
I just miss him so much it's so hard I
can't get rid of this drama I just can't
his son was one of the 135 people who
died when police fired tear gas at fans
at the end of a football match after
some Spectators entered the pitch it
resulted in a crush at the exits of the
overcrowded Stadium as people tried to
escape only to find many gates locked
now he says his heartbreak is mixed with
disappointment
what I wanted was for the people
connected to the shooting of tear gas to
get the punishments they deserve
at the Surabaya District Court one
police officer a squad commander of the
mobile Brigade who ordered his officers
to fire tiergas were sentenced to 18
months in prison two other local police
officers were acquitted the prosecution
had asked for a three-year prison
sentence for each of the officers
the mood in court was subdued only a few
relatives of the victims attended
proceedings many to hold Al Jazeera they
felt the lives of their loved ones had
been disrespected
16 year old brother was one of the
victims
we're definitely disappointed we regret
the judge's consideration was lacking in
thinking about the loss of 135 lives
to stay away from Court this week many
survivors told Al Jazeera they are too
traumatized and disenchanted with what
they call a lack of accountability from
authorities I always think about seeing
my friends dead in the hospital I have
lost my friends how come the punishment
is so unfair the site is now an
unofficial Monument to what happened
that night the shoes of Spectators still
line the steps of the stadium a sign of
how they desperately tried to escape
I have been following the case closely
because it's about 135 lives and now
it's like nothing happened at all the
case was handled quietly like many in
Malang he feels the seriousness of the
tragedy and the devastation it caused
for this community has been undermined
by this outcome Jessica Washington Al
Jazeera East Java